Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
I have been yearning for a light transport
paper, and goodness, was I ecstatic when reading
this one.
And by the end of the video, I hope you will
be too.
And now, we only have to go through just about
30 years of light transport research.
As some of you know, if we immerse ourselves
into the art of light transport simulations,
we can use our computer to simulate millions
and millions of light rays, and calculate
how they get absorbed or scattered off of
our objects in a virtual scene.
Initially, we start out with a really noisy
image, and as we add more rays, the image
gets clearer and clearer over time.
The time it takes for these images to clean
up depends on the complexity of the geometry
and our material models, but it typically
takes a while.
This microplanet scene mostly contains vegetation,
which are matte objects, these we also refer
to as diffuse materials, these typically converge
very quickly.
As you see, we get meaningful progress on
the entirety of the image within the first
two minutes of the rendering process.
And remember, in light transport simulations,
noise is public enemy number one.
This used a technique called path tracing.
Let’s refer to it as the okay technique.
And now, let’s try to use path tracing,
this okay technique to render this torus in
a glass enclosure.
This is the first two minutes of the rendering
process, and it does not look anything like
the previous scene.
The previous one was looking pretty smooth
after two minutes, whereas here, you see,
this is indeed looking grim.
We have lots of these fireflies, which will
take us up to a few days of computation time
to clean up, even if we have a modern, powerful
machine.
So, why did this happen?
The reason for this is that there are tricky
cases for specular light transport that take
many-many millions, if not billions of light
rays to compute properly.
Specular here means mirror-like materials,
those can get tricky, and this torus that
has been enclosed in there is also not doing
too well.
So this was path tracing, the okay technique.
Now let’s try a better technique called
Metropolis Light Transport!
This method is the result of a decade of research
and is much better in dealing with difficult
scenes.
This particular variant is a proud Hungarian
algorithm by a scientist called Csaba Kelemen
and his colleagues at the Technical University
of Budapest.
For instance, here is a snippet of our earlier
paper on a similarly challenging scene.
This is how the okay path tracer did, and
in the same amount of time, this is what Metropolis
Light Transport, the better technique could
do!
This was a lot more efficient, so let’s
see how it does with the torus.
Now that’s unexpected!
This is indeed a notoriously difficult scene
to render, even for Metropolis Light Transport,
the better technique.
As you see, the reflected light patterns that
we also refer to as caustics on the floor
are much cleaner, but the torus is still not
giving up.
Let’s jump another 15 years of light transport
research, and use a technique that goes by
the name Manifold Exploration.
Let’s call this the best technique.
Wow.
Look at how beautifully it improves the image,
it is not only much cleaner, but also converges
much more gracefully.
It doesn’t go from a noisy image to a slightly
less noisy image, but almost immediately gives
us a solid baseline, and new, cleaned up light
paths appear over time.
This technique is from 2012, and it truly
is mind boggling how good it is.
This technique is so difficult to understand
and implement, that to the best of my knowledge,
the number of people who can and have implemented
it properly is exactly one.
And that one person is Wenzel Jakob, one of
the best minds in the game, and believe it
or not, he wrote this method as a PhD student
in light transport research.
And today, as a professor at EPFL Switzerland,
he and his colleagues set out to create a
technique that is as good as manifold exploration,
the best technique, but is much simpler.
Well, good luck with that, I thought when
skimming through the paper.
Let’s see how it did.
For instance, we have some caustics at the
bottom of a pool of water, as expected, lots
of firefly noise with the okay path tracer,
and now, hold on to your papers, and here
is the new technique.
Just look at that!
It can do so much better in the same amount
of time!
Let’s also have a look at this scene with
lots and lots of specular microgeometry, or
in other words, glints.
This is also a nightmare to render.
With the okay path tracer, we have lots of
flickering from one frame to the next, and
here you see the result with the new technique.
Perfect.
So it is indeed possible to take the best
technique, manifold exploration, and reimagine
it in a way that ordinary humans can also
implement.
Huge congratulations to the authors on this
work, that I think, is a crown achievement
in light transport research.
And that’s why I was ecstatic when I first
read through this incredible paper.
Make sure to have a look at the paper and
you will see how they borrowed a nice little
trick from a recent work in nuclear physics
to tackle this problem.
The presentation of the paper and the talk
video with the details is also brilliant and
I urge you to have a look at it in the video
description.
This whole thing got me so excited I was barely
able to fall asleep for several days now.
What a time to be alive!
Now, while we look through some more results
from this paper, if you feel a little stranded
at home and are thinking that this light transport
thing is pretty cool, and you would like to
learn more about it, I held a Master-level
course on this topic at the Technical University
of Vienna.
Since I was always teaching it to a handful
of motivated students, I thought that the
teachings shouldn’t only be available for
the privileged few who can afford a college
education, but the teachings should be available
for everyone.
Free education for everyone, that’s what
I want.
So, the course is available free of charge
for everyone, no strings attached, so make
sure to click the link in the video description
to get started.
We write a full light simulation program from
scratch there, and learn about physics, the
world around us, and more.
Also, note that my former PhD advisor, Michael
Wimmer is looking to hire a postdoctoral researcher
in this area, which is an amazing opportunity
to push this field forward.
The link is available in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!